the high they reject nation I'm Greg
Alba time John Humphrey we're gonna
watch this trailer highly recommended
from a couple of close friends ready or
not it's a red band trailer from Fox
Searchlight no clue what this is didn't
hear about it till last night let's
check it out heard about last night
research that's kind of so at midnight
if to play game it's just something we
do and so a new high really
you can hide anywhere so there's no way
for me to win right
[Music]
[Music]
okay kind of like your next yeah there
next all right it's like get out without
any of the black people yeah it's such a
comic game gone awry would you rather
type things yeah it's like our we're all
getting together to gathering it's going
really nice but then awesome too messed
up can you survive the night I'm
honestly glad I didn't read anything
about what the movies actually about
because if I did I would have thought we
were walking into something a lot dumber
like that plot the plot idea I could
just imagine reading the plot that
sounds like a stupid movie sounds like a
like a truth or dare kind of films it
seems to have a lot more of a
personality to it that I much more
gravitated to this is really twisted
it's really - I like the like the
twisted vibe I like the humor about it
that it this actually seems kind of
funny it wasn't like you know chuckles
watching this trailer I was really happy
that it wasn't trying to go for a
complete full blown like self-serious
mood the entire time like well they're
all off the phone watching it I'm a
little bit confused as to you know I'm
sure they might give some brief my
explanation as to the motives behind
this rich white family gang oh yeah I'm
glad this ritual that they have to
perform or whatever well yeah what
extent of like supernatural miss applies
to that like is it some kind of ancient
blood right thing that they're just you
know continuing on or is it some actual
like satanic like is it gonna become
house the devil where they like raise a
demon by the end yeah how's that for how
big is it gonna get it what's the finale
gonna be this is the kind of movie that
I think usually the 2/3 of it are really
good and then the finale is where it
just loses itself my only concern about
this movie is literally what's the third
act gonna be is there gonna be
exposition dump are they gonna not
reveal anything is it gonna be
convenient is the twist gonna be
ridiculous you know like these are
usually the pitfalls in a movie like
this falls under and I'm not sure which
way it's gonna go but the immediate
adventure looks good I am the leading
who's the leading actress in this I know
I've seen her before and a bunch of
stuff Samara weaving otherwise known as
discount margot robbie am i right for
alien and everything is australian in
milan and young that is definitely
discount margot robbie hey if a logo
marshall green is gonna be discount tom
hardy it's an insult i'm sorry some are
relieved discount you're your own person
actors you don't have to be lumped into
them discomfort your robbie category i
was beating everyone to the punch before
they said she looks like she's doing
really good job there's something about
the levity of the humor that feels to
have a certain punch to it i like how
violent it feels it looks like one of
those movies is gonna have a lot of like
glee going on behind the camera while
you're watching you'll suffer on screen
like it looks like one of those kind of
lean mean horror movies to me those sort
of like pulpy violence that'll make you
laugh like it's so over the top that you
can't help but laugh at a certain
scenario there's some irony in there
yeah yeah just like really nasty looking
characters who also look like they're
gonna be pretty fun yeah you you know
well I like the the whole production
design of it to the production design
feels old-timey it feels a little
classical in its approach yeah you have
this like mad rich family so you can
feel free to have like the most
personality ridden giant mansion with
all these passageways and stuff like I'm
sure that out aspect will be pretty cool
well also with its sort of yellow
lighting that it has throughout feels
like a little candle lit and in certain
ways I know not the whole thing's
candlelit it has this sort of like soft
yet harsh grainy touch to it I was
pleasantly surprised by this trailer I
wasn't expecting to like it so much I
just thought it was gonna be some you
know silly horror film before we watched
it to me it's kind of cool to have a
horror comedy movie with with a little
bit of like a clue vibe an Addams family
vibe mixed in between at all you know
and I feel like those touches bring a
nice aesthetic to the landscape today it
looks like Samara weaving from the
babysitter babysit
it looks like she's gonna go pretty nuts
by the end of this movie - you had a
little image where she's drenched in
blood and and he has like laughing
hysterically it just seems like she's
gonna go insane as she should and the
husband is probably going to die like I
can't imagine him getting out of this
situation alive I that or he's gonna
turn out to be part of it all along and
you know trying to trick her you know
for a prolonged amount of time just like
and yeah it might be that like that like
yeah cuz it seems like he chose not know
your family it seemed like he knew what
the game was yeah it seems like he's
just trying to keep her alive throughout
throughout this game mm-hmm and there's
a lot of these accidental deaths that
are occurring in it I'm wonder if it's
gonna feel a little too slapstick well
that's what I'm I was sitting there
going is there's everybody else gonna
kill each other over the course of this
yeah the gonna kind of thing where you
have part way through there's like a
couple external deaths and then she
really like finds it within herself
unlocks her true inner survivalist and
then just yet goes nuts massacring just
everybody she finds that's kind of the
impression I'm getting yeah it's nice I
don't know it's nice for me to go back
just to that kind of setting it in a
house like this and having those kind of
Klu and Adams family aesthetics just now
on the fringes is fun just because I
love that setting for these guys even
the family all feels like they're of
that ilk just kind of set in the now you
know they're all like very fluid they're
very well-to-do I just find it funny
partly that they have their there are
games Empire they have all these games
they've created but they're like when we
get together we're going to play the
most classic well we're gonna play tech
guys build the brand and come on well
let's see where this movie turns out I
could kinda I kind of hope they don't
have a twist I just I just want it to be
a reveal just like a straight-up yeah of
like an explanation no I don't want to
twist yeah it was gonna be for yeah I
could settle with that anyway guys what
do you think of this trailer you just
pleasantly surprises us do you think the
trailer gave away the whole movie if it
did then tell me exactly how it's gonna
end if you think this trailer gave away
this is one of those trailers that you
just know it
to be literally here with the home of
him like no I don't think it did hey you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell if you
liked this video hit the like button
also download and follow us on the
Stardust app over there we do 30 second
reaction reviews for a new film TV show
and or trailer sometimes we post micro
sketches we pretend to post throughout
the week so do it today completely free
to download and use yeah
you